On Friday the 9th of April 2021, we received
the very sad news that His Royal Highness,
The Prince Philip, Duke of Edinburgh
had passed away at the age of 99.
His contribution to our nation serving loyally at
the side of Her Majesty The Queen for more than
70 years cannot be underestimated. In addition,
the young people in the District have benefited
significantly from participating in the Duke of
Edinburgh's Awards Scheme for a number of years,
a scheme founded by him which has enabled
many young people to build the skills
confidence and resilience they have needed
in order to make the most of their lives.
Our thoughts are with Her Majesty The Queen
and The Royal Family who have lost a husband,
father, grandfather and great-grandfather. I
have written to The Queen's Private Secretary
to express condolences to her and the Royal
Family on behalf of Rochford District Council.
The Council's flag has also been lowered to
half mast as a sign of respect. I've also
cancelled any civic engagements of a social
or fundraising nature during this sad time.
A period of national mourning has begun and will
continue until the funeral takes place at 3pm
on Saturday, the 17th of April. The Royal Family
has asked that during this difficult time floral
tribute should not be left at Royal Residences
and that we should all continue to follow
public health guidance, particularly on avoiding
meeting in large groups and or minimising travel.
I would therefore urge residents
not to travel to London
or any of the Royal Residences, in order to
respect the wishes of the Royal Household.
I know that many residents will be feeling
saddened and will want to commemorate this
sad loss; however, can I please urge you
to follow the wishes of the Royal Family
relating to floral tributes and to refrain from
leaving floral tributes within our District.
The website the Royal Household has suggested
that residents may wish to consider instead
making a donation to a charity of their choice
or to one of the Duke of Edinburgh's patronages.
Due to the need to maintain prevailing public
health coronavirus restrictions and government
has stipulated there will be no physical Book of
Condolence at the Council. The Royal Household has
set up an online book of condolence which
can be found at www.royal.uk/condolence
so that residents can leave their personal
messages during this national time of mourning.
Formal arrangements are currently being
finalised so we can all commemorate the life
of His Royal Highness The Prince Philip, Duke
of Edinburgh. Please go to the Royal Household
website at www.royal.uk/home-royal-family if
you would like more information. In the meantime
Rochford District Council will be holding a
two-minute silence in honour of His Royal Highness,
The Prince Philip, Duke of Edinburgh which
will be streaming on our YouTube channel
on Friday the 16th of April at 9 30 a.m so that
residents can watch live. The link can be found
on the front page of the council's website
www.youtube.com/user/rochfordcouncil